what's up guys welcome to our 100k q a
thank you so much for sending in your
questions and some of you even sent in
videos which was honestly so so so so
nice to put a face to some of your names
so i really appreciate that like i've
done before i've kind of grouped these
questions into different categories and
will cover everything from career mental
health school creativity but before i
just want to say thank you so so so much
for supporting the channel every time i
release a new video i am
quite amazed
that
thousands of people actually watch the
videos
and usually for architects to be able to
show their work to the world they might
spend months and months working on a
project and enter competitions for the
small chance that they might get some
publicity
so i feel very fortunate to have an
audience who watches my videos and is
willing to give me their time and yeah
just know that i really
appreciate this opportunity also
i have partnered with pacific arc who i
have been working with throughout the
year and they are amazing and i have a
architectural tool kit to give away
three of them and i'll be announcing
them throughout the video so make sure
you keep your ears open for your name
and stick around till the end because i
have some very very important channel
announcements alright so let's get
started
right now i'm in grad school in the u.s
and i'm struggling to convince my very
pragmatic minded thesis professor of my
conceptual ideas
and i'm wondering because your thesis
was somewhat conceptual did you face any
adversity trying to kind of ground your
project in the real world
when you were in school this is a great
question and i did have a very
conceptual thesis and
actually at the very first presentation
of my thesis here i got ripped apart for
my work
and that was probably one of the worst
presentations that i've ever done and
whenever you have a bad crit it's very
important for you to reflect on why
these juries gave you such a bad review
i think this helped me actually
re-strategize on how to present my work
and the overall direction of the project
so
yeah i was talking about super
conceptual ideas like the library of the
mind and like slow reading and
categorization
so i really needed something to ground
these ideas and for me
that was through aggressive case studies
and turning those case studies into
useful data so
one thing about case studies is that
they're really good for learning about
how other people have designed the
buildings but it's also a really really
great way to build
a defense for your design moves like a
lot of the times people do case studies
but they have a hard time showing how
they incorporated that and use that for
your project so breaking it down into a
very simple graphic
like this can be very helpful if you
want to learn more about how to use case
studies to create a defense for your
project you can go
here so once you've proven that and have
a real world foundation then you can
kind of step back into a more conceptual
territory and that was just my way of
doing it but there's also other ways of
doing it too one of my friends also had
a really conceptual project which was
about making and his project was all
about the process of
designing a building
and i think the most important part is
to turn your project into something that
could be
valuable
and contribute to the profession of
architecture
now that you are working
do you feel that you still get to use
that conceptual part of your brain
that you honed during school
not exactly in the way you would use it
in school the firm that i'm at does talk
about architectural ideas more
at a conceptual level than other firms
that i've been at but i actually
understand that this is a necessary part
of being a profession with like
deadlines and liabilities and you know
in the end we are providing a service to
a client who comes to us with very
practical problems to solve so i try to
exercise this more conceptual part of my
brain through you know these videos some
of these architecture videos like the
process of making these requires a lot
of like creating connections between
different things and i really like that
so i think having something on the side
where you could exercise that creative
part of your brain could be a nice
release for you when you start working
in the field does the choice of
different universities matter or do they
all teach the same things from charbelle
yeah so the choice of university
definitely matters some universities
focus more on the conceptual side some
universities are more technical and some
universities are more industry focused
so i would definitely do a little bit of
research before you start applying being
not so good with software what is the
best site to learn from and how did you
find the software that best suits your
workflow skillshare actually has a
pretty good revit course i have a
discount code if you want to use it you
can get one month for free and i'll
leave it in the link below and if you're
willing to pay udemy also has a pretty
good course on revit and on creating
families sketchup is pretty intuitive
and i never actually took a course for
it the other tool that i use pretty
often is rhino and udemy also has some
good courses on that as well and i
learned rhino when i was in school
through the courses that's that one of
my profs made i would say rhino is
probably my favorite 3d modeling tool
but i don't really use it anymore
because it's like super expensive
so i use sketchup for the schematic and
dd stuff and revit for everything else
but if you're in school like i would
experiment with these different software
because you do have the student version
which is free i think you'll realize
that once you start working the software
that you use
isn't really up to you anymore it's kind
of up to the industry
of your region and what the firms use
and how expensive the software is yeah
sketchup is like relatively cheap
compared to rhino so a lot of firms use
this and i found that a lot of firms
will use a more like fluid modeling
software like sketchup rhino for the
conceptual or the schematic or design
stuff
and then they'll move into revit for the
drawing and like the more complex bim
modeling my question is do we need a
good diploma in architecture to work at
a successful company or do they value
work quality more i'm going to refer you
to my video steps on becoming an
architect to get a more in-depth
response you definitely do need to go to
an accredited school and get the right
degrees but if you're talking like
quality of school i think going to a
good school definitely helps like if you
went to harvard or mit when you see that
on a resume you're automatically
impressed but that doesn't mean that you
can't impress people with your portfolio
like
i went to a school that was not that
well known so i really had to build up
my portfolio but when i started working
i had colleagues who went to harvard and
ubc so i think once you enter into the
field
everyone kind of starts at level zero so
i think what's more important is your
portfolio and your network like who you
know and who you can get a really good
reference from how did you deal with
burnout as a student it's from caitlin
so one of the
main differences between being tired and
being burnt out is that when you're
burnt out
you don't see a foreseeable improvement
in your situation you feel like you're
doing all of this hard work for nothing
and i actually know business owners who
work like 10 times harder than
employees but it's usually the employees
that you hear
going through burnout and i think that's
because if you're a business owner you
kind of see that the pain and the stress
that you're going through is gonna
eventually
lead to a progress in your financial
situation so one of the things that
i like to do when i'm feeling burnt out
or feeling unmotivated is journaling
journaling's had a pretty big impact on
my life from starting this youtube
channel to improving my relationships
and whenever i'm feeling like i'm in a
rut i journal this is one of my favorite
exercises so i asked myself what would
my life look like if i could achieve
everything i ever wanted in three years
and three years is not that close but
it's also not that far
so it doesn't really have to be
realistic and it can be
as wild or as crazy as you want but just
like write down everything that comes to
your mind
and yeah like something that you would
like to achieve or something you would
like to have in three years time but one
of the problems that i had when i was
trying to do this exercise when i was in
school is that in three years
i would still be in school but you know
there's still a lot of things that you
could do in that sphere and for me it
was getting really good at presentations
and becoming a confident speaker for you
it could be winning a scholarship or it
could be getting good grades or maybe
after your exercise you might realize
like you don't even want to be in school
in the next three years but i think
without a vision
you're just going through the motions
even if you're doing something as menial
as like doing renderings if you have a
big vision of getting like straight a's
you're going to feel more motivated to
figure out the best way to do the
renderings and like the fastest way to
do the renderings and you're going to
want to build systems and you might want
to try figuring out a different way to
tell a compelling story so yeah i think
a visioning exercise can be really
powerful and motivating but like if you
want to take this one step further
into
real actionable steps you can break this
down into smaller pieces and you know
try to just pick like two or three
things out of that list that's the most
important for you and you know like
break it down into habits that you can
do every single day to get to that goal
so the very first winner of the giveaway
is
justin soto congratulations justin you
just won pacific arc's everyday kit i'll
be in touch hi danny i was wondering
about the work life balance as an
architect
so as a student was the workload
manageable did students have time for
other pursuits
and as a working professional how's the
work-life balance
are the hours always really long and
stressful
um is overtime always expected i want to
be totally honest with you i did not
have great work-life balance when i was
in school you know i just wasn't that
good at time management
and i pulled a lot of late nights and
did a lot of all-nighters and eventually
i did get better at time management but
i was still working late nights and
i'm
pretty sure i've shaved off quite a few
years off my life just not super healthy
but i mean it probably was the time of
my life when i grew the most
and i do sometimes wonder if i would
have been able to produce the projects
that i did and like
got good grades and stuff if i hadn't
worked so hard and so i think there's
like two sides of this there's the
actual workload and there's the culture
of overworking in architecture looking
back i think the workload actually was
kind of manageable if i had been more
strategic about my time but i think the
problem for me was that there was a
incredibly steep learning curve you know
going from high school to uni
and the second thing was the culture of
all-nighters and people saying like oh
you can sleep when you're dead and that
combined with your studio project
because if you're really into your
studio project you could literally like
iterate and iterate and iterate over and
over again so when you have this mindset
and this culture around you where
everyone is like working around the
clock then you automatically think okay
like i have all night to work on this
project and when you're sitting there
for that long
your productivity just goes downhill
like you really need to let your brain
rest and like do some creative thinking
but
working late week after week you're just
more tired and you're not working fast
and you know there's this thing
called parkinson's law
that says your work expands
to fill the amount of time that's
available i think that's kind of what
happens in architecture school and the
other side is that when you're talking
about work-life balance it's great i
think the fact that we're talking about
this more is really great but i'm
actually a little bit afraid that it's
misguiding people and
no i don't think you need to work all
day all night and sacrifice your health
but i don't think you need to draw such
a hard line between work and life you
know especially when you're in school
you know you're investing thousands and
thousands of dollars in your education
and in your growth and in your
self-discovery
and this is one of the few times in your
life where you're surrounded by people
who are like smarter than you and more
experienced than you and they're paid to
teach you stuff also this is the time in
your life when you're gonna have the
most energy trust me it's gonna go
downhill from here so
when you're in school my advice would be
to actually explore your interests and
work as hard as possible but also try to
focus on building systems and this is
gonna eventually help you be more
efficient and not have to work so many
hours however
when you start working it's a totally
different story you know when you're
working no matter how much you might
like your work
you are still getting paid for your time
so you do need to draw some hard lines i
think as an architect and as a creative
professional
there are so many opportunities for you
to create your own side business and
you're not getting to use that time for
those other things that you could be
using your time for and there's also the
side of like if you keep working
overtime for free you're lowering the
standards for everyone in the industry
like for me i
had a really bad work-life balance last
year especially during covid but one of
my colleagues got burnt out and just
like left with
very little notice and that was actually
kind of an eye-opener for me i realized
that if i kept working like this i was
gonna burn out too inevitably like at my
performance review i told my bosses that
you know my goal moving forward
is to have better work-life balance and
to only work my contracted number of
hours
and they were
accepting of time i think we're all
learning from this and i think the
industry has been actually pretty bad
about work-life balance but it needs to
change and it is changing i used to
think that i had to get more productive
and i had to get faster at doing things
but i realized
it's actually
about prioritizing and saying no to
things and saying no to people which is
hard you know saying no to people is
hard because we don't like disappointing
people right i think controlling your
environmental factors have a bigger
and a faster impact than you just trying
to fix everything yourself
yeah my question is about your long-term
goals and plans as an architect when
you're an architect already what else
exactly is there to aim for do you have
a specific award do you aspire to
achieve
it's a good question yeah lots of things
um i still consider myself pretty much
an infant in the field
and i want to get more experience
working on different building types and
working with different types of clients
but
mostly i would say i really want to
learn
about the business side of architecture
and this is probably counter effective
for the partners at my firm but they
really inspire me and part of me really
wants to do what they're doing and i
don't know if i'll ever start my own
firm someday but you know i do feel like
we are kind of in the golden age of
entrepreneurship you know i'm not gonna
lie like the idea of building something
that's yours that's really attractive to
me but you know i just want to make sure
that i don't leave the nest before i
learn how to fly how was your life at
architecture school did you join other
activities along with school yeah so i
actually did do quite a lot of
extracurricular activities when i was in
school most of them were related to
architecture i was on the student
council so we organized parties and
events and stuff and as a first year
that was a really good way for me to
meet the older students i was also part
of this group called freedom by design
which was a non-profit organization that
helps retrofit the spaces for people who
have mobility issues and like makes the
spaces more accessible which is where i
met terry who was one of our clients and
he had ms and you know he actually
inspired one of my projects i used also
these they were called design jam night
or something like that and it was hosted
by um u of t university of toronto which
is another school in toronto and you
know they would let students come and
present their work so you could get
feedback from different profs and grad
students and it wasn't like a chill
bar setting and that's where i met my
friend dave who i traveled across the us
with to see franklin wright buildings by
the way
i'm actually working on a project where
i'm making all of those projects
accessible for people you know i have
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
notes from these buildings and i never
actually
properly shared them on the internet so
i'm working with my assistant to sort
through all of those and make these
accessible for you all so stay tuned i
also did a competition with some
building science students and it was
called race to zero i learned a lot
about net zero buildings and it was a
really good portfolio piece that was
built on real construction methods all
of these things gave me experiences that
i couldn't get in the regular school
curriculum and yeah it's had a really
positive
impact on my life so i would highly
recommend doing these extracurricular
activities if you can how did you choose
your job after the internship and exams
and could you possibly work at the
architecture firm you worked for in the
past yeah this is a great question and i
actually covered this in my video what i
learned on my journey to become an
architect i'll leave it right here and i
talk about the thought process behind
how i picked the firm just after
graduation when you just graduate those
first couple of years are so important
for your growth that i actually try to
tell people to try to follow people not
necessarily money or projects because
those first few years you
really need to be working under people
who are willing to teach you and you
need to be
in a place that has a culture of
learning but when you finish your
internships and exams and become a
licensed architect yeah you're still
learning but you know the fundamentals
of how to be an architect and you can
start managing your own project so
this is actually when your career really
starts and so now
you can start taking the other things
into equation like the projects money
company and people once you're at this
point and if you're interested in
growing fast as an architect i think
personally the priority now
should be the project and the firm what
kind of projects do you want to work on
and where do i need more experience
and you know are there different
typologies i want to try and you know
where can i go that's gonna let me
manage my own project so for me when i
was applying i just really wanted to
work on cool projects and i really
wanted to get more experience working on
like public and institutional projects
and i felt like faulkner browns which is
the firm that i'm at right now was doing
like the coolest work in vancouver but
what i'm realizing now
is that what's more important than
getting the cool projects on your
portfolio is the process and you're
actually there to learn the process that
produces the cool work and the next
question was would you ever go back or
could you ever go back to the firm that
you were at yeah definitely if you
wanted to and if you left on a good note
you could definitely go back to the firm
that you worked for but for me
working at different firms is the best
way to accelerate your growth because
you can learn from different architects
and see how each of them operate but
actually moving firms is really hard
because you know you have
responsibilities and you've built
relationships with people and you have
your projects that you're probably going
to want to finish and usually
architecture projects take a really long
time so
in an ideal world actually like i wish i
had another five to ten years to try
working at more firms and try working
under different architects so that
i have a larger research pool to
understand what i like and what i don't
like you know it's like if you married
the guy that you started dating in high
school you just know that one guy but if
you
try dating around
then you know what's out there and you
know what's good or not right
and the second winner of the giveaway is
mariana romero mendes congratulations
marianna i'll be in touch my question is
if you have any advice for anyone who's
currently studying architecture in one
country say the united states
but is interested in working in another
country say canada i would apply to
large firms and i would start early
because large firms typically have the
resources and systems in place to hire
people from abroad and you might not get
as much money in the beginning but it is
a good way to get your foot in the door
and you know get some experience in that
country and also start early when firms
hire someone from abroad it's either
because you're a recent graduate or a
designer or you have a very specialized
skill
and the further you get into your career
and you know once you become an
architect your experience gets more
specific to the region you're working in
you know in terms of the building code
or like construction methods and
you know most firms are going to be
hiring you to manage a project when
you're an architect and you can kind of
only do that if you have local
experience so
i would say
try to do this during your internship
and i think that will be the best time
for you to get that
international experience and get your
foot in the door in that region do you
find your job fulfilling and do you
specialize in a type of architecture if
so which ones so right now i do find the
job fulfilling but it wasn't always like
this i actually spent some time to think
about this because we have a couple new
interns in our office and i want to help
them you know get to a point where they
feel like this as well because the first
few years of my internship was kind of
hard for me
and i didn't really enjoy it that much
and
i think i
really only started to enjoy the work
and feeling fulfilled
when i had ownership of the project
instead of just doing a task and when i
started managing the project
or when i became the point of contact or
when i started controlling the output
that's when it became fun for me because
now i could actually see how the pieces
fit together and i could actually see
how the decisions that i made in the
beginning are impacting me during
construction and i think just my
personality type is
i think i'd like i want to say problem
solving
but maybe i just like talking to people
so
yeah i like working with different
clients and consultants and the other
part that's been fulfilling is like
helping the new interns and this is
actually the first year when i
started having someone help me and you
know usually i was the help frame like
the process of teaching him and like
figuring out the most effective way of
helping him and helping him learn i
think that's been pretty rewarding as
well and to answer the question of
do i specialize in any type of
architecture um i don't really
specialize in one type but i have done
quite a few small interior fit outs and
i'm also working on a library and my
thesis project was a library and i think
libraries are just so cool and i would
love to keep doing more of this so this
is a long question but i think it's
important that i read out the entire
question i understand these types of
injustices have been happening but see
the political social and economic events
and issues unfold at a global scale
especially in 2020 i feel as though
architecture does not have much of an
impact to help aid and solve some of
these issues considering who can afford
architectural services or design in
general even with good intentions of
solving or bringing awareness to
political social economic issues through
our work it is still up to the client at
the end of the day if these things are
in line with their needs and wants
understanding that impactful change can
occur more at an urban planning level
through establishing policies and etc
than architecture what then can
architecture truly impact at an everyday
scale is architecture's impact different
in that it exists only at a
phenomenological level this is a great
question julian and i used to think a
lot about this too one of the big things
that i've been learning a lot about is
creating an accessible and equitable
space for everyone you know a place
where you feel welcome no matter what
age or ethnicity or gender or you know
whether you're in a wheelchair or your
hearing impaired and
i didn't really learn about this in
school but now cities are really pushing
for a more accessible space for everyone
especially in the public realm in the
public project you know like libraries
or community centers it also depends on
what type of architecture you want to go
into architecture is so broad and you
really have to design your own career
you know some architects are not
interested in this you know like you
said they might be more interested in
construction or phenomenology
and maybe for this
a smaller scale like a residential
architecture
might be better suited for you but if
these social issues are high on the
priority list for you i would recommend
that you go to a firm that does more
institutional projects and not so much
private projects i think the fact that
you guys are asking these questions
and
really wanting to make a difference is
really cool
and
don't let this die out when you start
working and i think it's a part of your
job to protect your optimism and not get
so jaded by the realities of
construction i think the architecture
industry has been kind of stale for a
little while but right now i think the
environment is kind of ripe for some big
changes in the industry i don't know how
far along in school you are but when you
get into the field learn and absorb all
the information but don't take the
status quo as your standard you know
things that i'm doing at my job i
personally find this rewarding but you
guys are gonna be smarter and you're
gonna be more connected than me and so
you know you guys can do a lot more yeah
like i wouldn't take the architecture
industry as a standard and you know
don't accept my standard of fulfillment
as your standard and you know pave your
own way and
change the world i have a question about
your career
if one day your youtube career outrank
your architecture career i mean from
money clients fulfillment freedom and
even pressure would you continue to be
an architect or be a full-time youtuber
i feel all the architecture youtubers
struggle to be consistent including you
i think the short answer is yeah
absolutely if i hit a point where
youtube gave me more
money clients freedom
fulfillment than being an architect i
would definitely quit architecture i
don't know if it's ever going to be able
to bring
me fulfillment like i'm actually really
curious about this so let me know in the
comments do you really think that making
youtube videos are gonna be able to
bring you fulfillment or even more
generally if you could quit your job
would you and for me i'm just speaking
for me one of the reasons i started my
youtube channel is so that i can do
architecture and
do it the way i want
without compromising my values and doing
what i like and being creative and doing
interesting work on a daily basis is
very important to me but you know who
knows my interests could definitely
change over time i think one of my
strengths is that i'm pretty clear on
things i enjoy and things i don't enjoy
because at the end of every day i
journal and i try to answer three
questions for myself what excited me
what drained me of energy and what did i
learn and that's why i spend most of my
youtube income on paying editors because
i'm not interested in cutting videos you
know just like i'm not interested in
becoming the best renderer or the best
draftsman or drafts woman and i learned
how to do them but you know i'm not
interested in becoming an expert in them
i do know that i really enjoy designing
and creating and writing and researching
and storytelling and building and
working with people and those are the
things that bring me the most
fulfillment right now and i think the
sweet spot for me is somewhere between
architecture and youtube maybe i can
have my own firm
where i can do both and i can control my
time and i can kind of choose the type
of work i do
so yeah i think that would be
the sweet spot how can you manage your
time between your work and video editing
so for a lot of my videos the simple
videos like the q a's or the videos
where i'm just like talking and
delivering value i try to outsource most
of that i've gotten to a point where i
can outsource almost 100 of those videos
i rarely need to touch those videos i
just film it send the footage i've
already created the templates and the
structure and editing guidelines like i
don't really need to spend time working
on those for the more high quality
videos like the architecture videos that
i release on a monthly or bi-monthly
basis those ones actually i have a more
experienced editor that i've been
working with here in vancouver and we
are actually in the process of starting
a film company called noli media i will
leave the links
to the website in the description if you
want to check it out but the goal is for
us to create yeah these more high
production quality documentary style
architectural videos and yeah we're both
really interested in exploring the
filmmaking side of architecture and how
we can tell a visual story of
architecture typically what happens is
i'll create the script and for those
videos it's like very very tightly
scripted
so i'll spend most of my time on the
script and the research and i'll
storyboard the videos and kind of plan
out like what i would like to see in
each area what type of b-rolls what kind
of imagery what kind of music and then i
start to work with my editor on the
editing process and i pass off the
footage and the script to him and he
starts the editing process and it's kind
of a back and forth from there and so
that is a more intensive editing process
and the way i've structured my channel
is that i'll have a couple of videos
where i'm just like delivering value
it's mostly me talking in front of the
camera and then i'll have something
around like one out of four videos that
are these like more high production
quality videos which are the videos that
i'm personally like more interested in
making this balance helps me have a more
sustainable
channel and a more sustainable you know
work-life balance and yeah i think
that's how i'm able to make it work hi
danny here's my question if you could go
back 10 years and give yourself one
piece of advice it could be architecture
related or youtube related what would it
be hey anthony by the way guys anthony
went to architecture school with me
years and years and years ago
and he also has an awesome youtube
channel uh you guys should check it out
so that is a tough question if i could
give myself one piece of advice and one
only this will be
by bitcoin
joking this question actually made me do
some serious reflection because it's
really asking you know if there's one
thing and one piece of information i
could have known ten years ago that
would have had the most positive impact
on my life
what would it be so ten years ago
that's around the time i would have
started architecture school and i think
one of the biggest and best realizations
of my life
is that ultimately people only care
about their own problems and their own
[ __ ] that's going on in their lives and
mostly they're gonna forget about all
the dumb [ __ ] you've done unless you
slap the mc at the oscars i feel like i
wasted a lot of time looking for the
approval of other people but in the end
i just needed approval from myself
and
one of the best
things i did was
kind of
shut down that part of my brain that was
constantly worried about what other
people thought and start this youtube
channel it has really
rewarded me handsomely
so
that's the advice that i would give
myself
10 years ago so i have two announcements
before we continue i was super excited
to get your questions but what do you
notice only one girl
sent me a video and i know for a fact
that i have a 60 40 male-to-female ratio
on my channel from my youtube analytics
and i've gotten so many questions from
female subscribers this is actually a
very common scenario like women are
often very underrepresented um
especially in the architecture and
construction industries
so
we need to take every possible
opportunity to support each other and
learn from each other
because you know the challenges that you
face as a woman in this field
is you know let's face it very different
from our male account of heart
so on may 21st and may 22nd for the
first time ever my friend joanne and our
team is hosting a women architects
festival if you don't know joanne she's
the founder of women architects
collective facebook group which is an
incredible
supportive community for women in the
aec industry especially when i was
working by myself this was my go-to
place for asking questions the women's
architects festival is kind of born out
of that and it's a virtual conference
they've got some incredible speakers
they're going to be covering topics like
personal branding burnout motherhood
mentorship the conference is taking
place from may 21st to may 22nd
and i've got links to the tickets in my
description so i would highly highly
highly recommend you check it out but
the second announcement it's for all of
you over the past couple of years this
channel has really blossomed into
something beautiful and it's been a
really great community and i've
connected with so many of you and i've
been inspired by you so i've decided to
create a discord server
where i can connect with you but you
know more importantly where you can
connect with each other and share your
work and share your ideas and share
resources
and have meaningful conversations about
things that you guys are passionate
about
right now i am only opening it up to 50
seats
because i actually want to you know get
to know you and you know you just have
better interactions with a smaller group
i really want to build this into a
robust supportive community before i
open it up to people
if you are interested in joining this
group and kind of helping me lay the
foundations of this community i have a
quick questionnaire for you down in the
description the selection process is
going to be really dependent on the
dynamic of the group i would love to get
people from adjacent fields i would
encourage like those of you who are not
in architecture to fill out the
questionnaire as well i'm calling the
server arky beans
i don't know why it was like the first
thing that popped into my mind
but um yeah like i see this as an
evolving thing i've just kind of created
the initial framework
and it's going to evolve to best serve
you and the community fill out the
questionnaire if you're interested in
helping me build the foundations of this
okay so the question is
what other creative projects interest
you outside of architecture so i am
really interested in storytelling and
you know its ability to grab people's
attention in both video and audio
formats i'm kind of in the process of
turning my thesis project into a series
of videos not really because i think i
had such a cool project it's really not
because i'm trying to learn how to turn
something kind of complex like an
architectural thesis into something more
digestible and interesting for people i
heard somewhere that one of the most
important traits of an architect is
someone who can explain
exactly why they prefer something i
think it's so fascinating
how architects get into architecture and
you know find this new world of
expressing the world and we're totally
engrossed by it but yet the general
public or the normies has no idea why
we're obsessing over this detail
and i think we just haven't really found
a good way to communicate it to the
world and the process of turning my
thesis into a video it's been really
eliminating
because it's given me lots of insights
on my own education like first of all we
didn't have a maximum word limit on our
thesis and we had a minimum worth limit
but with video you want to be as
efficient as possible with your words
and deliver as much information in as
little time as possible so just by that
it tells you engaging a larger audience
has never really been an architect's
priority but i think it should be the
other thing that i've been really
interested in is audio storytelling or
audio journalism which i think is a
totally different beast and one of my
favorite things in the world is podcast
and my all-time favorite podcast would
be this american life if you don't know
about it it's a collection of stories
from different people and every episode
it's on a central theme
and one of my favorite stories there's
so many it's hard to choose it's
probably about love
and whether we can teach ourselves to
love people who are hard to love and the
third and last winner of the giveaway is
amanda lang
congratulations amanda i'll be in touch
so what are some things you do to keep
inspired or help you learn about
architecture right now
i'm not reading too many architecture
books or sketching at the moment and
when i have time to read i'm reading
more about business books i'll just
refer you to my website link that has
all the books that i would recommend and
yeah i'm reading more business books and
it's actually more of a logistical
problem more than anything i listen to a
lot of books on audible you know when
i'm walking or exercising and lots of
architecture books just are not
available in audio format and i
have to say the things that inspire me
the most right now are just like being
involved in some of the projects that
are like shaping the future of vancouver
which is where i live i think one of the
advantages of being an architect in a
city that's like relatively
underdeveloped or relatively new
compared to cities like rome or new york
is that the city is also trying to
figure things out and it's like testing
new policies and you can really be a big
part of the city building process and
like work with the planners to
try to direct things in a more positive
way i'm also trying to get into the
housing market in the next year or so
and i like living here these urban
planning policies have a direct impact
on me that gives me more motivation to
get involved the other thing
that's been inspiring for me is like
working with the librarians on the
library project you know they're super
knowledgeable and passionate about the
libraries and
working with them has been really
inspiring i think all of our civic
projects even if they're just like tiny
renovations they're under
this city's new goal of like providing
accessible
equitable space for the widest possible
audience and so yeah that's pretty
inspiring for me as well even if i'm
doing like a toilet layout i'm kind of
like
yeah this is actually going to help
someone my colleagues and the partners
at the firm are kind of i guess a
constant source of inspiration for me
you know especially when i watch them
navigate really difficult conversations
like one of the partners he's quite
soft-spoken he's a soft-spoken british
guy but he's just got this talent for
like gathering the focus in the room and
cutting through the noise and just
clarifying the goal for everyone while
making everyone feel at ease
you know even in the most complicated
situations so
yeah that's something i'm trying to
learn as well lastly like growing this
youtube channel has been really exciting
and inspiring seeing this youtube
channel grow
and talking to students and other
architects and architecture enthusiasts
when i was first starting the channel
like people were telling me not to make
a channel about architecture because
it's too small of a niche but look you
know there's a huge amount of architects
and people who are interested in
architecture i think to sum it up what's
been really inspiring for me lately are
the people around me just doing amazing
things and
creating
everyday miracles
[Music]